wide distribution of people today
very cool
Fort Worth
Jamaica it's Apollo Brazil
gold El Paso
famous west Texas town
Atlanta Michigan
Nigeria
Arkansas
Brooklyn
we have a daughter who is moving to
Brooklyn she lived there for a while
she's moving back
Toronto
very cool
sir Ukraine
California India okay we're just about
to start now so
thank you for letting me know where
you're all from appreciate that
and
I'm going to uh
switch over
check
and
I want to start
recording in progress
I'm going to welcome in a LinkedIn live
audience so we'll just take a moment as
we
Dan and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience
as well as to um
our YouTube live audience and everyone
on Zoom of course
my name again is Stuart Creek I am with
simply learned we're the delivery
partner for Caltech Center for
technology and management education
and this session today is about
the data analytics boot camp
um data analytics is a really important
field we'll be talking about that about
the kinds of careers and roles that are
available in there you'll be hearing a
little bit from Mike yeah she'll
introduce him in a moment
um and we'll talk about how this
boot camp prepares you to work in this
field
we'll go over the curriculum features of
the program
we'll talk about some learner outcomes
and then I'll share with you uh
enrollment steps if you're interested
and also the bonus offer for your being
here today
we'll be offering you a bonus
if you have questions
for me put them into the Q a in Zoom
uh or if you're on the streaming service
you can put them into the chat or
comment box
and we'll see if we can get those
transferred over from there
but if you put your questions in the Q a
box and zoom I'll be able to see them
more clearly
um
let's start by hearing from Mike Ash
I'm going to share with you some
comments he made in an earlier session
of this presentation
so
hi everybody I'm Mike Ash uh a little
bit older than my my picture uh I'm a
director for the center of technology
management education we're a part of the
California Institute of Technology that
engages industry and and government with
learning programs these include public
programs and boot camps like what we're
going to talk about today there are also
several others that are really designed
for technology driven organizations
uh and I've been here in Caltech for
about five years working in high tech
for 25 as a project manager and and an
analyst
and spending a lot of time in data
analytics and in charts and strategy
what we want to do today is talk a bit
about what's happening with careers and
data analytics we can come at this from
lots of different directions but I think
everybody knows that
digitizen digitization and
digitalization are all these uh new
powers of being able to uh use
computational power
um and really data Rich environments can
transform uh businesses science
um every industry and
as consumers of data and generators of
data there's just an incredible amount
that's out there and organizations need
to be able to understand
how they can harness that and part of it
is operational data or from the internet
of things some of it might be customer
data
financial data and there's just so much
we really have to use better tools and
and better analytical methods to
understand what is this really telling
us what kind of insights can we get from
having all this data and it's not only
just a growing field but it is a huge
opportunity for for people who want to
bring an analytical mindset
to work and so we'll
we'll talk about that
um this is a a growing field uh
skyrocketing field is is more like it
um and being able to start in analytics
there are entry-level positions out of
out of undergrad of course out of
Masters or graduate programs
and they're they're very lucrative
um and even in a
in a tight economy the need is still is
still there uh what a learning program
can do is not only help you understand
how to use data and how to manipulate it
how to manage it be a better steward
but like I said be able to interpret
what's what's there and having that
interpretation role
um whether as a scientist or somebody
who's really just using data and
information for business
um
there are several opportunities
um and roles in organizations some of
these are
listed here on the page but being able
to use statistical analysis or Advanced
tools and coding like with python
Tableau for visual visualization
um AWS for new cloud-based platforms
and really just getting into uh
statistics and tools uh like regression
and machine learning we won't go that
far into machine learning in this
particular when we talk about this
bootcamp for the data analyst there is a
separate program in data science that's
much more
machine learning Centric
uh you heard a little bit from Mike
about
data analytics and the opportunities
there and you're all here because you're
interested in data analytics as a
potential career field or as a career
field that you're in that you want to
enhance
What stopped you from taking a program
of this type
uh up until now I'm getting
further certified in data analytics I'll
leave this poll open for about 25
seconds or so on Zoom if you're watching
on LinkedIn you can put your ABC or D
into the answers
uh into the um chat or comments there
so is it because you can't find a
comprehensive program that covers all
the skills Mike showed you um
because don't have confidence you get
practical experience to demonstrate new
skills
because the learning style doesn't fit
your learning style or is it because you
can't find time in your schedule
close this in five
four three
two one
and
the main concern people have is not
feeling that they would have practical
experience examples to show from their
program to be able to demonstrate that
they have the skills that they claim and
also finding time in their work schedule
so we'll be talking about that in just a
second here
and
the data analytics boot camp from
Caltech ctme
has a comprehensive curriculum
industry aligned because ctme's mission
is like said is to help Caltech transmit
its expertise and its its knowledge base
the industry and other organizations by
training professionals so they keep a
close tab on what industry needs in each
of the job roles that they talk about
and
or data analytics they've come up with a
curriculum that helps you get ready for
the kinds of jobs that employers have
told them
they bill
um
this is a fully online program it's six
months you do everything from your
desktop or laptop
you can watch parts of the program there
are certain self-funding videos that
help you get prepared for each week's
live classes and you can watch those on
your mobile device if you want to but
you can do any of that 24x7 the only
parts of the program that are scheduled
are the live virtual classes that happen
on weekends
generally from 8 to 12 on Saturday 8 to
12 on Sunday so you devote eight hours
to each weekend there's live classes
um you say about 10 to 15 hours a week
overall in the program on average and
um
you need to plan to have your weekends
available for this program but if you
missed something
the you can refer back to a recording of
that week's class so
uh it's all there at your fingertips and
it's all uh that includes the labs and
the projects which are done on a Sandbox
environment Jupiter Labs on your
learning management system platform so
you access it through your web browser
don't need to download software or buy a
system to to do the work it's all there
uh in the virtual machine dedicated to
you
and so
this is designed to fit the schedule of
practically every working professional
so
that I'm going to move on and talk about
the
benefits that you receive at the end of
the program end up with a
certificate from Caltech that attests
that they attest that you have learned
the skills that they've promoted in the
program that you can demonstrate those
skills
so this
certificate carries a lot of weight
because it comes from one of the Premier
institutions in the world
uh you have a final project in the
program we call it a Capstone project
and that ties together everything you
learn in the program so along the way
you'll be doing
projects for each course within the
program but then you'll do a final
project that ties everything together
and acts as one more practical example
of your experience with the skills you
get a membership to the online Caltech
CTE Circle
which allows you to network with other
people who've taken these programs and
get information on an ongoing basis from
Caltech ctme
and you get recognized that a
online convocation where you can invite
friends or family to watch as you get
recognized by the name by
folks from Caltech and simply learn
to recognize your accomplishment for
completing the program which is no small
thing and you get career assistance
through simply learn so after you get
your certificate you'll have support in
your job search if you are using
this education find a new job or a
promotion so
we'll talk about
Caltech as an institution
now Caltech is the California Institute
technology it's founded in the 1890s
and it is one of the greatest
concentrations of very bright people
in the world there's a reason why when
Chuck Laurie wanted to make a sitcom
about
brilliant people he decided to set the
Big Bang Theory at Caltech
because that's where a lot of brilliant
people work some of the people there
earned Nobel prizes for the work they
did there
some of the people who earned Nobel
prizes elsewhere came to Caltech to
continue their research knowing that it
has the uh
excellent facilities and also the the
other people around them that will help
them
do their work better so Caltech is uh
private school it is not part of the
University of California system or the
California State University system
independent and
it concentrates on producing
people with graduate degrees and phds as
well as its research Mission
home to a lot of centers and
a lot of
Laboratories like the jet propulsion
laboratory which is NASA's arm for
building
and deploying
um
deep space probes planetary probes
and they actually build the probes at
Caltech and send them off to
NASA facilities for launch so Caltech
ranks in the top five universities
worldwide it as I said carries a lot of
weight so people see that on your resume
and they will
understand that that certificate means
something
for this program it's very open you do
not have to have prior knowledge of
programming or technology this program
will take you from
very basic level so you get all the
foundational
training you need to keep up with the
program even if you're coming in from
zero technology background uh you do not
have to have prior work experience
either you can come straight out of high
school
um you have to be at least 18 years of
age with a high school diploma
equivalent
um so if you have if you're in
University currently if you're
you have a bachelor's degree or any
other higher degree if you're a working
professional all it's open to pretty
much
everybody and it's designed so that
people will succeed from every level but
also that people at every level
will learn valuable new things so
it's not
not tailored
to a vocational program for high school
graduates it's tailored to be an
advanced program
where people wanting to get into data
analytics
so quick question how much experience do
you have
this is just to get a feeling for who's
in the audience
I'll just leave this open for about 20
seconds or so
pretty straightforward question
again A B C or D if you're watching on a
streaming service
and I'll close the poll
in five
or
three
two
one
and
we have about 20 percent of our audience
or folks who are still in school the
rest of you are
working professionals
with the biggest contingent being people
with more than five years of experience
hope I'll be able to share with you what
makes this program appropriate for
people at all levels talk about the
the programs
curriculum and structure and it goes
step by step
starting with an induction session for
um
the boot camp that teaches you how to
use the learning management system the
platform itself how to find your courses
how you'll go through them in sequence
and roll for one meet the requirements
to complete it and then unlock the next
one along the way you unlock a
certificate for each of the component
courses so you build up a set of
certificates up until the top
when you unlock the final caltex
certificate for the program
so you'll learn about Excel which is a
basic data analytics tool that people
this is
um
gone a long way from the original
version
that competed with what was called
lotus123 back in the very old days
um
so now it has Advanced Data handling and
presentation uh
functions
you'll learn how to do presentations of
data the different styles of presenting
the insights extracted from data by data
analytics in a way that communicates
effectively to the audience you're
talking to different audiences require
different presentation Styles and
different visualizations of data so
you'll learn about how to Be an
Effective Storyteller with the data then
you'll learn about SQL which is of
course how to manage a database
it's
a basic module on
how to organize the data that you will
then use to
derive insights through analytics tools
you'll get instruction in Python
scripting language so that if you don't
have a programming background you don't
have to worry that this module will
teach you what you need to know about
basics of programming for
data
analytics and using python scripting
language then you'll move into using
Tableau which is more advanced
visualization platform
and this allows you to do better
storytelling create things like
dashboards for management
we move on to data analytics on AWS so
that you understand how to use
cloud-based
environments for data analytics
and
um these skills are transferable to
whatever Cloud platform you're on
whether it's AWS the Azure Google cloud
or something else
finally you get to the Capstone project
the final project of the program which
is about a three to four week
module where you're given the choice of
several different industry aligned
problems
things that you would actually be called
on to solve as data analyst
and you pick the one that interests you
most
spend three to four weeks building your
solution for it
you meet with your instructor weekly so
that you don't get stuck on any dead
ends or rabbit holes and at the end of
that process your project gets graded
that's what unlocks your final
certificate but it's also something you
can take with you into the future and
show off as your experience sample so
uh
tools and platforms you'll learn
mentioned a few of them in the
curriculum
and
Excel SQL python when we say that you'll
learn them that means you'll actually be
called on to use them in each of the
courses
so you won't just be exposed to these
you will in fact have to um
employ them
and demonstrate that you know how to use
the tool you'll have then examples that
you can show off
the potential future employers about how
you use Tableau or how you built a
data applications Within
um
Excel
I'm sure I can chat with everybody here
oh sorry
just putting into the chat a reminder
about
a q a
sorry
and
we talked about the Capstone project
briefly we want to mentioned it again
because it's such an important part of
this program
um at the end of the program you will
have learned
SQL Excel tableau
the final Capstone project gives you a
challenge that is based on a real life
problem you might find in Industry as a
working data analyst
and you then need to use all the
different tools that you've learned
along the way in the program to build
your solution
so
Capstone project gives you something in
your GitHub portfolio that goes along
with all the other pieces of the the
program
all the other projects that you've done
along the way in the different courses
and that Collective portfolio gives you
proof that you can show off
the potential future employers or to
your current employer let's say now I
have these new skills
I can
justify asking for a better position
better salary
I'm going to share with you this
brief video
uh this gives an overview of
the learning platform and how our
courses work it gives an example from
one of our other partners which is
Purdue University and their digital
marketing program that we do with them
but the platform tools are the same so
you'll get an appreciation through this
video
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading Tech
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports under audience
Graphics this is super useful especially
if you're running ads for example you
could do it on social media later you'll
learn social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions so
other than other interesting question on
the chat box and say that oh to optimize
in YouTube you can use the rising
session of Google Trends and optimize it
okay so let's go back to here right here
where it says web searches and you can
see that there's going to be the YouTube
searches okay so now you can see that
the YouTube searches is going to be so
there's a option uh under not just web
search and there's going to be a YouTube
search okay so just go ahead and click
on user search and you should be able to
optimize your search results
so what is Instagram
app Instagram app referred to when we
come across any sort of
Instagram apps would appear within those
new contents so you would be caught when
you are watching an original video and
leave you a video app and then go back
to the original
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice
tackle practical problems with multiple
projects and simulations and work on a
real world Capstone project that you can
showcase to Future employers your
learning isn't restricted to just live
classes explore our highly effective
self-learning videos and other resources
to fine-tune your learning and remain up
to date always you can focus on
different learning approaches by subject
to personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right and so we've talked about the
learning environment you can see from
that you manage your curriculum you pick
which class you're working on when you
finish that class you unlock the next
one in the sequence so it takes you
through in a step-by-step fashion
I saw a bit about the live virtual class
environment in which the instructor can
take you through live exercises you can
ask your questions live they can ask you
questions live go along with them and do
the exercises live alongside them uh you
saw the platform for doing programming
for doing labs and projects tests and
assessments
talked about the Capstone project and
how to unlock your certificate and along
the way you have 24x7 support so you
have a community feature allows you to
pose questions to your matchmates into
your instructors to the instructors in
the course at any time 24 7. you also
have a 24x7 support desk in case you
have any questions about how the
platform works or what a contact a
simply learned a support person about
the course content
um that way if you're working on a
project at three o'clock in the morning
and you reach a stumbling block you can
always
reach out for help so
the program is under the direction of
Rick Hefner who is
the overall executive director of
Caltech ctme he's Mike Ash's boss and
he's been in
technology for 40 years
academics in insulting in
industrial positions and in research and
he oversees all of the offerings from
Caltech ctme for professional education
make sure that this curriculum is as I
said aligned to the needs of Industry
so this is a Caltech program simply
learned is just here to deliver it
talk about the learner outcomes
these are the people you're going to be
learning as aside our matches come from
information technology banking Financial
software Pharma Healthcare retail so
this is a broad range of of companies
because eating analytics is
essentially used universally
every organization needs to understand
how its operations are going
of how its marketing is going what sales
are happening what forecasts are in the
works and data analytics provides those
answers and insights so everybody needs
it
have people from industrial companies
from Consulting companies from
e-commerce from banking
from a healthcare from every sector in
your batches your classmates
will be able to
pair notes with them and do some
networking with them
and as I mentioned before we offer a
service this is for folks in North
America
US and Canada I apologize to people in
other countries that we don't offer
sorry don't offer the career assist
service there through this program but
this is a six-month period after you get
your certificate this gives you Services
through
our partner Talent Inc to help you with
your job search
uh it also emphasizes the projects that
you've done in the course as your
experience samples and we also have a
series of webinars that allow you to do
essentially continuing care and feeding
of your career so the talent Inc part
the formal
job search assistance
includes access to their job portal for
six months that gives you a way to
search their employer Network for jobs
and then apply without exposing your
resume to a public site like dice or or
Glassdoor where your current employer
might see it
instead you have a discrete and
confidential
job search environment you also have a
couple of other services that I think
are equally important if not more so
because
resumes today don't go into human beings
desk or screen until they've gone
through an automated tracking system
and
an AI bot has evaluated them so the AI
Bots job is to take a look at the
content of your resume your skills
experience
and match that against the job
description
knowing how to write a resume so that
the AI bot will filter you into the job
search
say you're a match rather than filter
you out by saying you're not qualified
is an important skill
but then your resume does go on to
somebody's screen or desk and it has to
still be visually appealing to a human
being so balancing those two
requirements is a very important service
that this program provides
to work with a professional writer who
can make your resume work for both of
those
similarly with the interview prep
service you get one-on-one sessions with
real human beings to talk about the
different ways and practice the
different kinds of interviews that
you'll have to go through ranging from
the phone screen with the HR or
recruiter to the technical interviews
and what to expect from your potential
peers and supervisor about the questions
you'll get around your skills and your
knowledge of data analytics onto the
management interviews for do you fit in
with the company culture do you have the
work ethic they're looking for are you a
team player so all of these different
styles of interviews you get a chance to
practice live one-on-one with human
beings these are valuable again these
extend for six months after you earn
your certificate
and those are not a job placement
service or a job guarantee they are
valuable for you to use
your job search
I also talked about the webinars you get
a weekly series of webinars that simply
learn runs these are at no cost to you
they're available to you lifelong and
you can
see sessions on what's the state of a
particular technology or technology
sector today what's going to be
happening in the future what are the
trends what do you need to know to work
in that sector
um how do you get into a new type of
Technology where
you find jobs how do you how do you
conduct a job search effectively
prepare your tools for that job search
how do you generate the soft skills that
you need or career healthy and
progressing over the years so all of
these are available to you on an ongoing
basis
so talked about the program costs which
is ten thousand dollars can be financed
at low interest rates at uh 8.81 a month
um and I also have mentioned the bonus
offer so today
uh for attending this webinar you will
be able to claim a 500 discount off
those program fees taking it down to
ninety five hundred dollars
also you should know if you have an
employer who offers tuition
reimbursement
check with your HR department or your
Learning and Development Department and
find out if they will help defray the
cost of a program like this
that's a valuable benefit and if you
have it you should use it
um so I will put into the chat
the email address that you want to use
to contact us
for
getting started with this or getting
into answers questions
that is ask us at simplylearn.net
that's in the chat right now
and
quick question based on everything that
Mike and I have shared with you are you
interested
in joining this program
I'll just leave this open for another 10
seconds
five
four
three
two
one
and about two-thirds of our audience
today are interested in
the program so let me
share that with you show you that and
then
share with you how to get enrolled and
you you email ask us simplylearn.net
Caltech and simply learn will ask for
some basic information you need to
demonstrate your age and and your high
school
diploma or equivalent we will do a brief
assessment test of your knowledge of
basics of math and programming but again
that's not a requirement that's just to
see where you are in
assistance and getting up to speed for
the program
and once we've
vetted your qualifications we'll send
you an admission offer
so our next cohort starts
with an induction session on March 29th
and about one week from today
and the actual classes start May 15th
expect to be there on May 15th or four
hours four hours the next day to get
into the first
module of the program
we say to hurry because limited seats
are available you may ask yourself
why an online program has limited seats
answer is this is not a self-study
program
this is not a massively online a
massively open online
course this is based on live instruction
with classes that have to be limited in
size so we take cohorts that are about
25 to 30 people at the most
in order for the instructors to be able
to devote sufficient time and attention
to each student
so if you're interested in getting
started you should contact us right away
and see if you can get into the pipeline
find out about this cohort or be a
future cohort if this one doesn't suit
you
and let me ask that question of you
are you interested if you're interested
in enrolling
are you interested in getting started in
the make cohort or maybe the one right
after
and again I'll just leave this open for
another 10 seconds
and we'll close this in five
four three
two one
[Music]
I will share with you the result
using my weak eyes
about half of uh our audience are
interested in getting started either in
the mayor perhaps the next cohort after
that June July and for those of you
looking further down the road
please do contact us and ask us
simplywear.net we can then keep in touch
with you uh
keep you advised of future cohorts
answer any questions
and at this point I'm going to take your
questions
and
first I want to check to see if any of
them got transferred over from our
streaming audience so far no
so focus in on the questions that have
come in through
our q a
and
so you have an anonymous question can I
become a data analyst without a degree
the answer to that is yes you do not
have to have a degree if you have the
skills
and if you can demonstrate those skills
having a certificate like this one
gives proof without when you're having a
degree it gives proof that you have
those skills that can demonstrate that
you do this type of work so the answer
to that is yes
um
you have a there's a business project
project manager
plus your product manager PM
um who
um this would be a side skill this is in
fact an important reason
to take this type of a program if you
are in management if you are in a
technological for example engineering
position or any position that needs to
be able to understand data better and
then tell the story of the data about
what about which you are working
um this is an important skill set to
have
um for example in manufacturing
the notion of a lean Six Sigma and
statistical process control is entirely
Based on data analytics
understanding
data analytics beyond the basics of
the r bar charts that type of thing
can be extremely helpful to somebody in
that environment
uh
over
how is this program different from the
AIML boot camp
and this is a a great question it comes
from
foreign
er
um
the AIML boot camp focuses more on
the modeling
of data
creating models and algorithms and
understanding the process by which
machine
models data models and the
self-modifying
so that has more data becomes available
to model to the algorithm it can fine
tune its results and provide better
tracking and predictions of what the
data says
so there's machine learning which is
that basic process and then there's an
artificial intelligence which goes a bit
farther into drawing
um
insights from data and then deeper into
that neural networks which
try to replicate
some
natural thinking processes so the AIML
program will go into advanced topics
like speech recognition natural language
processing Machine Vision that type of
thing if you are interested in
developing those types of applications
that's a great program for you if you
are looking to just apply your skills
and be able to
work as a data analyst or as I said to
use data analytics in your current work
this program is an analytics program
it's great
I am in my 30s am I too old to switch
careers and start this no
um there is actually no age limit
uh simply learn in Caltech don't post
one and employers
need enough people
to help in these areas that they're not
um
ageist as much past you might have heard
of
or feared the notion of being
overqualified or uh
being regarded as too old to learn new
things
in fact if you have taken a program like
this and earned a certificate you have
conclusively demonstrated that you can
learn new things and you conclusively
demonstrated that you have the kinds of
skills that people need for data
analytics jobs so
um
your 30 is just not a factor in your 40s
is not a factor in your 50s is not a
factor we have a testimonial from a
learner you did in fact take the AIML
boot camp uh in his 60s uh in order to
be able to start a new
Enterprise so
again age is not a barrier
I am looking at
is this a merit-based field
uh this is generally speaking a
merit-based field
this is a kind of field where you will
be judged on the results you've achieved
um so
if you are able to
do the work
create the insights
and communicate them effectively
um
you'll be valued as a
High producing employee
and that opens up both higher salary and
advancement opportunities for you
um
if you're not able to do those things
people are going to turn to someone else
who can so yeah this is a merit-based
field
um
what can I
kind of jobs can I apply for if I have
an LSS certificate I'm not sure I
understand that question because I'm not
sure what the LSS certificate means
um
I know that this certificate qualifies
you to apply for jobs and data analysts
what is the difference between this
program and data science
data science again focuses on the models
and algorithms and understanding how to
construct those
so you might think of it as
the data scientist will
look into
the available data about a phenomenon
try to come up with different ways to
understand that data develop different
models and algorithms pull insights out
and see which ones best describe the
data and best predict what the data will
tell you
um the data analyst takes the tools of
the data science scientist has built and
applies them so
recognize which set of tools apply to
which sets of data
and then use them to generate the
insights and format them into a story
that tells that
your management
I hope that clarifies that a little bit
will we utilize pivot tables vlookups
yes uh
we'll we learn more about how to use
GitHub yes
shown how to do that as part of the
program
um
making the Google analytics courses this
the same or similar structure
the if you are taking a course
I can't comment on what Google does or
their teaching style
um
but I do understand
I can comment on simply learns teaching
style and caltex program
and
this is going to be
very interactive as I said it's limited
in the number of seats per batch so that
you've got interaction with your
instructor and a lot of support it comes
with a lot of the self-study but I don't
know whether Google analytics program
has that same set of features
um
this program focuses on python not r
the data science program includes R
because it's
another
layer of tools
um
will we be able to network on a specific
site when we complete this you will be
able to network with other ctme
graduates specifically
uh you'll be able to then use resume
rabbit and see what you're saying about
resume rabbit but yes
um
you will have the ability to communicate
with other professionals through the
ctme uh
Circle membership and that includes not
just people they studied with in this
program but all the people that Caltech
has trained
you're their ctme so
pretty broad range of individuals
uh can I reiterate yes the fee is ten
thousand dollars U.S get a 500 discount
for being here today
and the program is six months the
uh when you enter the program you should
plan that for the next six months you'll
be spending your weekends doing this
work
um some of the classes don't require
live some of the courses don't require
live classes so you hit some of those
weekends off for that and if you do miss
a weekend session
um occasionally you'll be able to catch
back up but you do
see with each course you'll see the
requirement for how many live classes
how many uh self-study classes and how
many projects you have to complete in
order to complete that course and move
on to the next
uh
uh we will send it a recording of This
webinar
um to you with a
email that I'll send out after this
program after this session
and
you're asking a specific question about
minitab tslc processing
microstrategy in qlik I can't answer
those specific questions our lending
consultant that asked us at
simplylearn.net may be able to help you
with that
um
in
admin tab is something that
definitely we cover in
lean Six Sigma program that we do but
this is a whole separate thing
is it necessary to have any level
previous experience not for this program
you do not have to have previous work
experience
um
and
I think that covers all of the questions
that I've seen I want to take a quick
look
see if there's anything
chat window
with the different programs data science
data analyst AIML is there a
track
there really isn't necessarily a track
although if you start off with data
analytics it's a good foundation to move
into either data science or the IML
program and
data science is a little bit less
comprehensive than AIML
I'm overlap there though
data science
Camp also includes machine learning as a
module but it doesn't go deeper into the
AI functions so
um
who says that I've got a master's degree
in applied statistics and data science
looking for hands-on experience
this program
gives you some hands-on experience in
terms of being able to demonstrate
problem solving
um
so
I'm not sure what your master's program
has included in terms of actual examples
of problem solving but this this program
is very much based on learning by doing
is the program available to Mexican and
Latin American audiences it is available
throughout
the rest of North America and South
America as well the instruction however
still is in English and unfortunately as
I said we can't offer
the career assist to services in those
countries
see
thanks
that
covers all of our questions
oh I want to move on to a final question
for you and the audience
appreciate your patience
so if
you would like to reach out to you and
have a learning consultant contact you
say yes if you want a
proof of attendance for attending
today's session
the answer yes to this question and this
will um we'll send that to you as well
I'll leave this open for five seconds
four three
two one
and a little more than half of you said
that you'd like us to reach out send you
a proof of attendance and answer
questions for you so we'll do that
I will contact you after this session
it'll be in the next day or two
but I'm going to put into the chat one
last message for you which has the URL
of
the
Caltech data analytics boot camp
home page our simply learned site
that's in the
chat right now
and I want to thank everybody for being
here you can use the QR code also to get
to that homepage
and please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net for any additional
questions or to get the ball rolling
we would love to welcome you into the
Caltech and simply learn learning
community
and that
includes our webinar for today remember
that you if you roll
uh
be able to claim a 500 discount for
having been here today so that's our
thank you for uh attending today
and
um
would love to see you in our cohorts in
course in the future
have a great rest of your day